because if you don't and you're always
catering to their level of IQ yeah
they're just going to be [__] yeah
that's true like taika this morning he
goes Papa where are you going he sees me
in my backpack and I'm like I want a
Legoland with all my friends niggles
tell me the truth
[Music]
all right so this
article right here allow me to explain
as best as possible the context before
making too many quick judgments let's
make quick judgments guilty let's go
straight to Quick judge we like to judge
here these are fun pretty fun I think
they're racist the headline is Florida
police officers are accused of jailing
their young son over potty training
accidents okay what they jailed their
own son I knew that race to teach them a
lesson though yeah so Florida police
officers accused twice of putting their
three and a half year old son in jail
cells are they parents Mom and Dad yeah
oh and they're in the police force and
they put their son three and a half
years old in jail cell to punish him for
potty training accidents that's harmless
you gotta teach him a lesson yeah it's
just it's like bringing their kid to
work yeah but wouldn't it be funny
though if he's sharing that cell with
another hard murderer and he's like what
you in here for a kid he goes I went the
baby in my pants yeah I [__] the bed I
went to pee pee in my pants he goes oh
that's rough and the way he talks about
it he's like yeah like I did some
hardcore [__] at home like I shut the
bed you know my sister I get all scared
of him yeah he's like whoa this guy's a
fruit let's get [__] to the bed yeah I
feel like it's like an episode of scared
straight you know and you're just like a
[__] unruly toddler and then they're
like or go to jail or we don't know how
bad the kid was at potty training maybe
he was just really bad he keeps [__]
himself he's like machine gun [__]
all over them to the level where he
deserved to be jailed well I mean
obviously why you have the smirk on your
face what I'm not smart you're that's a
smirk that's not a smart that's a smart
you literally have the curled lips on
the side of this Market yeah you see the
smoker I see your smart my smart yeah
so um obviously you know things get
really really dramatic and stuff like
that they were interviewed by a state
child abuse investigator who was
escorted to their home by you know this
County Sheriff's deputy whose body
cameras on and recorded the conversation
can they just [__] arrest them yeah
just it's just what are you gonna arrest
you know I'll arrest you child abuse
investigator
[Laughter]
now all the whole family Goes to Jail
the parents have to go in there with the
kids how did you even make the news
what's going on so everybody's just
totally like yeah just take your kid to
work then there's no problem here yeah
that's what I would do I would love to
throw kids my kids in jail if I could it
would be funny yeah scare the [__] out
of my life literally being processed
there's a mug shot record yeah just
handcuff himself using a room I tell my
I tell my kids every day I'm like I'm
Gonna Leave You at the [__] pound
dude I say that all the time how do they
take it well you have kids
you want to answer his question huh you
have kids yeah I have two pugs so I have
two kids oh where are you saying Anthony
why'd you say oh like that dude they're
[__] they're real babies okay oh yeah
oh another dad
so what happened so tell us the big
[__] reveal dude no there's no big
[__] reveal or anything like that
it's it's just a matter of like it's
kind of uh there's two sides to it right
there's people that are like this is
child abuse and then there's is it
though the parent side that's kind of
like yo like it is really like take my
kid to work there they they claim that
they have oh it's like for real they
also have an older son where they did
the same thing when he was younger and
it worked haven't your parents like
faked call the cops on you before when
you were a kid yeah it's just that kind
of [__] you're just trying to teach them
a lesson it's not like no real harm and
then it worked because I was like no I'm
sorry I'm calling least and you're like
no I can't go to jail when I when I got
caught stealing candy when I was in like
fourth grade at the supermarket from
those bins of candy and I was trying to
be all slick and my pockets were just
filled with candy bro it was like
ridiculous got too greedy dude and I was
like pretend to be like oh what's this
over here I was putting stuff in my
pocket anyway that was a menace man my
mom was like talking [__] to me she was
like she was like I'm gonna call the
[__] cops on you like you're gonna go
to jail you're not gonna steal [__] I'm
just like I'm so sorry no it didn't work
because you kept on stealing stuff from
Target I did I haven't in a while and
then she called the security guard who
was like a cop in my eyes any grown-ups
I was like I'm sorry bro and then when
she pointed the security guard I
remember being like like on another
level bro like it's over like I'm gonna
be locked up
[__] we're family dog how can you do
this to me yeah for real I felt betrayed
as first gen Asian Americans I think we
always have a higher threshold for what
child abuse is true because they
actually got abused like anything like
that we just hear we go because that's
amazing is like oh that's parenting yeah
yeah depending on you get your ass
whipped for no reason what the kids
Behind Bars like this going right yeah
that's a cute image but I think that's a
[__] this guy had a hide in a
grandfather clock dude I think we're I
think we're such a heavy minority in
this opinion though I think the greater
Nation I think the greater Nation really
thinks that's child abuse but we're just
like I think certain ethnic are gonna be
like what are you talking about bro this
is nothing yeah come on dog yeah I do
that right yeah I mean but everyone got
their ass beat I think if people don't
even know like let's say they don't even
have an opinion they're they're tending
to sway on agreeing with it out of
safety but Asian American first
generators are just like openly like
that's nothing yeah that's true or I
feel like those strong American families
are probably that's nothing too yeah I
[__] locked my kid in the barn yeah
but I think some people some people tend
to think that like that agreeing with
that helps prevent it in the future yeah
you know it's like more of a
forward-thinking thing but we're just
like look dude I don't think there's
anything wrong if both of your parents
are police officers they want to take
yeah to jail for like
like it's worked in hospitals and they
would [__] with me all the time and and
like if I was coughing to be like oh
that sounds bad oh you know what you
know what could be could could be a
considered child abuse is when Jimmy
Kimmel makes all his viewers send in
videos of like the Grinch running and
stealing presents and running out isn't
that why they discontinued that oh
really yeah they stopped doing the
Halloween the Halloween prank because
they deemed it child abuse so I think
this isn't the same ballpark they stop
they stopped doing the Halloween thing
we're like oh I ate all your candy and
the kids start crying they literally got
complaints oh my God you need to kill
those parents that's what I'm telling
you like it's it's a thing where like
even if you don't really believe it you
feel inclined to take that side just for
the uh The Virtue signal yeah can we
have like a like a new class in high
school with like unpussy 101 or
something yeah
like imagine like
let's say they're both Olympian swimmers
yeah if they want to throw their kid in
the pool to teach them how to swim
they're gonna be the best lifeguards to
save the kids that's what happened to me
exactly right my cousin say here who are
you to not be an Olympian swimmer to
complain about the way that they're
teaching a kid how to swim that's true
yeah that's true yeah so I think 101
I think the father actually articulated
this pretty well he said uh to the kid
he's like I said you know what I do for
a living I said I'm a cop I take bad
boys to the jail that don't follow the
law so that's what I did I said you know
you aren't following the rules let's go
to jail I just used his profession
honestly don't think it's a big deal at
all that's what I'm saying because to a
cop a jail cell is just a room like it's
just a room at your job yeah it's like
if like when I was a kid my parents
would leave me in a room at the hospital
while they finished work and I would see
that's [__] up bro to them it's
different but like to another person
they're like how dare you put them in
front of like patients with their heads
cut off like so what
find a little more cool though dude
right like I don't understand this whole
like insulating yeah what are they
making people from the world yeah that's
a new thing that's why we're all in
trouble yeah we're gonna make some weak
ass generation whatever they want they
just want the kids to keep pissing in
their [__] beds all day yeah oh it's
he's 18 now it's fine I think this [__]
works I think you gotta scare the [__]
out of your kid alone yeah dude the cop
parents they don't they don't have time
to clean beds they're out catching bad
guys yeah catching bad guys man you
think they will come back and see the
pissed bed like bro I gotta go I gotta
go yeah I'm not trying to attack [__]
nuggets I'm trying to catch Bad Dudes
[__] yeah come on [__] nuggets I
feel like when you were a kid adults
were always like kind of messing with
you all the time
just makes you smart yeah like it's
smart like just like either like
bantering like oh why are you doing that
like like or just just teasing you yeah
just messing with you bro like I feel
like I do that to kids all the time and
I realize like oh I'm the only one doing
it but I think that's how you help kids
develop like true common sense and
critical thinking because if you don't
and you're always catering to their
level of IQ yeah they're just gonna be
[__] yeah that's true like taika
this morning he goes Papa where are you
going he sees me on my backpack I'm like
I want a Legoland with all my friends
niggles tell me the truth
and I was like no I'm just kidding I'm
gonna go I have to go to work sure don't
are you really
really good you can start deducing yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and
then next time you ask him where he's
going so I'm going to Deja Vu
any parts like wait who are you going
with I need to go with you
hold on let me get my sweater
so so what else is in the curriculum in
on [__] 101 yeah what else
don't take life too seriously [__]
around more but all of our parents think
we're [__] [__] ass [__] dude 100
dude and they're they're right they're
right I love that I love that they think
that I think that's great yeah my mom
what your mom thinks you're your heart
your heart she thinks you're a saint mom
thinks I'm stupid oh my mom thinks I'm
stupid too don't worry is in like IQ no
no she's just like come on why don't you
go
I want a Marines I'm gonna shoot some
[__] and my mom's like
you're stupid like that you know I mean
I was always like I'm gonna do this
because I want to do this and she's like
yeah you're stupid what does she think
about you wanting to join the the
sheriff she said why would you do that
it's like you're gonna kill yourself
what's your answer I was like what are
you talking about
good future benefits baby you want to
retire
go baby and sacrifice myself
he's really trying to join the LA
Sheriff oh yeah dude yeah yeah let's go
pass the background let's go I got I got
multiple tests hello hard though uh and
then the physical right after you did
the physical already no check your balls
they go can you cough for me Sheriff no
but I didn't realize the multiple the
multiple test is just High School
comprehension yeah I mean you don't I
need is hard is that hard for reals I'm
not gonna lie man that thing was kind of
hard everyone said Mark my life is like
what are you talking about this is easy
and I'm like I know that's the problem
it's not yeah you might be
no no yeah so you got to read a
paragraph and it simply goes what what's
the problem according to the passage
I'm like oh did I even read this
correctly yeah [__] you're still gonna
pass for LA Sheriff's though I think you
should start at Montebello mall security
and then oh it's not gonna help me with
reading comprehension
Journeys
city did you sound out your words if I
do it quietly it started going so this
guy Joe went up the street and it goes
Joe went straight down the street it
goes like that you're dyslexic
when I read it out loud I get it no
you're he's gonna pull you oh he's gonna
be like this is the problem bro yeah I
think it's like wait a minute you should
just be you should trap for Hawaii
Five-O first
no I did actually NCIS Hawaii
no I think so I got to believe in myself
it's a process I got it I will that's
why I'm taking the practice test now
take a bunch of them if you pass
background I think that's already a
pretty good step okay but if I can't do
reading comprehension how am I supposed
to write my report don't say that on the
video yeah I mean practice hey you just
need practice Doug hey in college I was
doing this
[Laughter]
that's what I'm doing right now Joe Bro
dude hey you'll be fine man that's part
of it I got it I got it as long as you
know there's some guys out there who are
reading that test and they go I'm a good
[__] reader and they're and they're
probably really bad at it at least you
know that you're like I want to do some
work just shoot the right guy
mostly most of the time you'll be okay I
just want the benefits man the benefits
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]